Hello friends and family.
I am Kevin Rose.
Welcome to another edition of the random show.
I am Tim Ferris,
and also welcome to number 347 of the random show.
I am your bald cohost today.
We're twinsies.
Yes,
yes.
We decide to go for a little shave.
Nice.
I think it's very a suiting.
It feels very flattering.
Really.
You think so?
Your head is bigger than it's like William Shatner.
No,
it's not.
Our heads are the same size by the way.
We measured them.
We measure this conference of our heads and they're actually also match.
Daria says waste.
Oh,
that's right.
My wife's waste is the same.
That's kind of weird.
Why don't we hit what the,
yeah.
One night he came over,
we did that and we know where are we right now?
We're in the it.
This is this how the man cave?
Is that the man cave?
This is just my office at my house and uh,
I've got a little chalkboard behind this ear.
So sometimes when we're doing a little product brainstorming sessions with a few
of my coworkers,
I'm on absolutely want to build stuff like that.
We get up here and move the couch away and just light board.
I think this was for tiny back in the day,
one of the absolute built about eight months ago.
And yeah,
it's all tiny.
So I haven't touched this.
We got an office so we don't use as much.
And you have sort of an art deco,
uh,
metallics are stainless steel chandelier,
which used to be deer antlers.
Did you swap it out?
Honestly,
this,
this whole room used to be very like man cave.
He,
like you said initially where it was a dark leather,
it's a dark leather big desk with leather on it and stuff.
And I'd just like,
you know,
that was my dad.
That was kind of like what he liked,
you know,
and I wanted to make it seem kind of Woodsy,
which is fine,
but I just wanted a little bit more space and something a little bit more modern
and that's why I got this couch and I don't know.
Um,
so it's kind of turned into this area where now my desks off against the wall.
I've got a bunch of open space in front of me.
I can just come into your lounge.
I got a little aims chair there that can kick back and read a book,
something like that.
So it's going to,
and you have a lot of whiskey.
What?
Japanese whiskey.
So what are you drinking today?
Um,
I just got back from Tokyo here a couple of weeks ago and this is a whiskey that
they have yet to release in the United States.
It's um,
they're Hibiki harmony whiskey and so it is a blend of I think four different
whiskeys.
And so he'd beaky is one of my favorite Japanese whiskeys.
I hadn't thoughti whisky.
Suntory.
Yeah.
Um,
so I have a,
I have the 21,
the 30 there.
I also have a 12.
Um,
honestly I think for a day to day drinker this blend,
I'm not sure what it would retail for in the states when it does eventually get
here in Japan,
I think it was 99 or 100 bucks for a model.
Got It.
So nothing crazy expensive.
Um,
for our daily Swig.
Yep.
This is just a,
it's,
it's when you're drinking the age whiskeys there,
they're very deep.
That will a lot of depth to them and a lot of complexity when they hit your
tongue.
This is just mild chill.
Like you can just kick back on a nice level,
a nice sunny day.
Throw a big cube in there and don't feel like you're killing it.
Cause it's like,
you know it doesn't,
it doesn't.
You know how when you do proper age whiskey,
you don't want to dilute it down to,
I just feel like you have to be too precious.
Exactly.
Now if you have those Sam,
I'll try it a little.
He's not drinking right now.
Good deal.
Don't think sip.
Take a sip.
I'm not going to fake.
Sometimes you fake sip.
Just take a little sip.
But any seen you fake sip?
I don't know.
Sometimes you don't drink that much.
Well that's true.
Meaning I don't drink as much as Kevin Rose.
Listen,
I don't drink as much as well.
I guess a decent amount,
but not that much.
I don't drink as much as I am and leaving Las Vegas.
Oh wait.
Yeah.
Hey listen.
I've been tracking my drinks as we mentioned in a previous episode in that
spreadsheet.
How's that gum?
I don't drink that much.
I drink a little bit,
but not that much.
Five or six drinks a night?
No,
no,
no.
That would be insane.
I was like alcoholic level,
like I would say an average night for me is probably like 1.75 all right.
Meaning there's some nights where I had three glasses and there's some nights
where I have zero
are using fishbowls as glasses because I know I've told my readers before you
can have one glass of red wine at night and they find out all,
they figured out all sorts of creative ways to basically make self-defeating
decisions to drink out of like a fishbowl.
So Darren's think I'm kind of,
I think some kind of nut nuts.
My wife,
because I'll come in and I'll actually measure out the ounces of wine into the
glass to make sure I get the rapport.
Because before I was like,
oh,
there's like three classes per bottle of wine or four,
but I think it's actually like four and a half or is that
all right?
750 mil.
Yeah.
So anyway,
you have to be,
I've also,
I've been measuring it out if I get kind of crazy,
but I'm,
I'm loosening up on that stuff a little bit.
It was fun to track it for the first few months and I still am,
but I don't know what the goal is at this point.
Like I know how much I drink and I'm pretty comfortable where I'm at.
I'd like to look into push,
push the envelope a little up,
up at four or five.
This is interesting.
I want to talk about scaling back on,
on this kind of stuff because for me as we get older,
I'm approaching 40 you're approaching 40.
Like we look good to think about that.
While I was going to say 50 blending will be fucked up.
Um,
we,
we like,
you know,
fat sticks to us a lot easier.
And actually we had dinner a couple nights ago and you're on this really funky
thing,
love Funky,
but it's like different than your four our bodies,
stuff like that for a sec.
Yeah.
I'm doing
and falling what's called the key to genic diet.
[inaudible] so I'm in a ketonic state.
What does that mean?
That means that I am running on fat predominantly.
So my fuel is coming from fat,
my fuel's coming from fat.
And what that means in pragmatic terms is that I am eating probably 80% of my
calories or so from fat,
which is a lot harder to do than you might think.
Uh,
and then perhaps 15% from protein and 5% or less from carbohydrates.
And I'm doing experiments to see what knocks me out of or not.
And the way that you actually just tips,
take a step back.
If you were to crash in a plan and the flying tomorrow,
where are you saying?
Right.
So let's just say that you crash and you're,
you're stuck in the wilderness.
Hold on.
You can survive three hours without shelter.
Three days without water,
three weeks without food.
Okay.
So you can go without food for a long time.
What happens when initially your brain's going to be trying to work,
uh,
utilizing glucose and blood sugar and over time that's going to become untenable
because you're not consuming carbohydrates.
And then we'll start pulling it from the muscles and the liver and so on.
Eventually you run out and that's when your body kicks over into utilizing body
fat for fuel and converting it into ketones.
So ketone bodies can be processed by the brain and heart really,
really well,
actually.
They're very helpful for endurance exercise.
So is this good for you?
Like is it,
I heard this a mental fog that happens when you first started going into it.
A transition from glucose dependent,
a ketone,
uh,
adapted or Keto adapted can produce some fog,
but it doesn't have to last more than a day or two.
But for a lot of people it'll take four or five days to get there.
This is essentially the Atkins diet more or less,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
And,
uh,
so this is a new toy that I've been playing with,
so it's not quite a toy,
but it's a a,
it's a medical device called the precision Xtra.
And this looks like,
and is a glucometer,
meaning I,
uh,
so I put a needle or you can do this here.
I pop,
I hit my finger,
I could do it live.
Maybe I won't do it live.
I've done it on my fingers and it hurts so bad.
Like it can't hurt,
especially if you get,
I was measuring and I had been measuring four times a day and I have two strips
per measurement.
So I'm putting eight sticks in my hand per day,
per day.
Now I don't recommend that talk to your medical professional,
but,
uh,
what's so cool about this particular device?
Or you can go to Walgreens and buy all sorts of glucometers leave.
You didn't talk to your medical professional about your like,
Hey,
I'm a stick myself eight times.
Let's say you're a fucking idiot.
There you go.
Alright.
Dr. Rosa is delivered the verdict.
These,
that's a caveat that I provide because you don't want to get sued.
Yeah.
Because someone like sick themselves,
one out of every thousand people out there as a fucking retard and they're going
to be like,
oh,
Tim said to stick myself.
No,
fucking stab myself in the eye.
All right,
so talk to your doctor before you fucking stab yourself in the eye.
Um,
these,
these particular sticks are for measuring ketone bodies and these are for
glucose,
so you can do both at this device,
which is very,
very interesting.
And uh,
because previously as you know,
and you have,
I see on your desk some Quito sticks.
Well,
I just got this can throw them in those grammar,
that little a white bottle gnome in front of that right there.
Yeah.
Um,
I got this because you started talking about,
and I was like,
well,
I'm going to try this for like weeks.
And he was saying like,
you lose fat like a Mofo,
like you do.
Yeah.
You can have a come cabs like starting to come out.
Now my motto ad is slowly becoming maybe a drab,
we'll move all moving towards a six back.
I've lost a ton of fat and I had some,
I blend my hips apart doing too and eat too many squats,
uh,
for just like squatting on a daily basis for many days straight.
And so I,
uh,
from ability not for,
for hypertrophy and took two weeks off,
had my first workout today and all of the weights felt light.
And now I'm not saying that's because of the Diet,
but my joints feel incredibly,
uh,
they feel much better than they did two weeks ago.
And I've been on the diet for maybe a week.
I'm going to do another probably four or five days and do a secondary round of
blood testing.
But here's,
here's the thing that's interesting.
When you go into Ketosis,
there are different ways to measure ketosis.
So when you pee on these,
you are,
you're,
what this is detecting is a cdot acetate being expelled in the urine.
Uh,
and this is kind of reliable.
You have a color coding on the side,
which tells you whether you have negative ketones,
trace small,
moderate or large.
All right Liz.
Then I would rather pee on a stick.
Then you get stab myself eight times a day.
This gets me,
this gives you the millimolar concentration to keep ketones,
which is very,
very specific.
Now the problem with these,
for instance,
um,
you could also measure it with your breath.
There's something called a [inaudible] device.
I think that's what it's called.
Ketonic excuse me,
with an end.
And you breathe into it and that will measure acetone.
And so it's also more accurate than this.
The Nutanix,
I would say it's more accurate than this because if you become fat adapted and
you've been in Ketosis for a while,
so let's just say Atkins Diet,
whatever,
uh,
your body becomes more efficient at processing ketones and you won't excrete as
much.
And so you then you'll,
you'll pee on this or do you want to be a little more,
uh,
reliable?
You can dip it into your urine for 15 seconds,
pull it out and you might come up negative.
But in fact,
you're rocking and rolling.
It's just that your body is not experienced with the breathalyzer thing.
Catch that.
The Breathalyzer,
uh,
I don't know how adaptive the Acetone expulsion is.
I think that that also probably diminishes over time.
If I had to guess.
So the holes I,
this was $12 for me at Walgreens.
How much does that to the precision Xtra is not that expensive.
You can get it for like 35,
40 bucks now.
But here's the thing.
All right,
so that is how much?
12 bucks.
And how many are there?
50.
Yeah.
Okay.
I know these,
these,
these are little strips for ketones.
These are like $5 a pop.
Uh,
they're really,
really expensive.
Uh,
so this is cost prohibitive for most people,
especially people who are as OCD as me with,
uh,
with sticking themselves three,
four times a day.
So that is the story.
So how much is the breathalyzer thing?
Gosh,
that test toaster for ketones.
Ketones.
Why would you hurt my dog?
Not going to hurt your dog.
Your dog is getting a little buxom.
He's leaves look a little chunky monkey.
What do you think he's got an extra for?
We haven't him lately.
He's a,
I don't want to send to super cute.
Come on.
I'm not saying he's fat,
he's just fat her.
Uh,
what else?
What else is going on?
Let's say what all on how much of the breathalyzer cost?
I don't know.
I think that's between like 102 hundred bucks.
Okay.
Yeah.
So can we,
one thing people are going to be wondering is like you have a very successful,
for our body book,
it's kind of like this and that.
I'm sure you do kind of go into ketosis with the foreign body a little,
hey,
you can go into ketosis on slow carb.
It's not the objective,
but it can happen.
And I'm logging all of my data secure and then transferring it over to Evernote.
Everyone is wondering,
why are you doing this?
Uh,
I'm doing it because I constantly test different diets.
Number one.
Number two,
you die.
It is selected based on what you're optimizing for us right now.
Uh,
I have some weird blood markers.
My blood tests have a number of items that have come back really weird and I
want to see if a ketogenic diet changes that.
And I want to see if it's autoimmune related,
if it's food related.
And so doing a lot of blood testing before and after,
uh,
for trying to identify,
how tweaking these variables effects on those things.
That's pretty much it.
You said it was making your joints feel better.
This has done is like,
is it a antiinflammatory diet in some sense?
Well,
in this to the extent that a lot of people would consider carbohydrates
inflammatory,
uh,
or at least process carbohydrates are those that are,
that are,
that are converted to glucose very quickly.
Uh,
Yep.
Then it would definitely be considered a antiinflammatory diet.
Do you think that's impacting?
You said your joints are feeling better now that you're on the side be,
it could also be the fact that I'm consuming 80% of my calories from fat and
eating like coconut oil and cheese and all this other stuff that,
uh,
might help lubricate the joints.
And I'm not sure how synovial fluid is,
is produced,
which is the,
the fluid that you find in say the knee,
uh,
but feel pretty good.
Now on the flip side,
eating all of this fat,
my skin is not so happy.
Big Surprise,
right?
When you're eating like hunks of metal using cream and coconut oil.
My a year sebaceous glands.
That's what kicks out the uh,
the oil,
it causes acne.
Uh,
not so happy.
Pretty grumpy.
So we'll not sure.
Not sure.
I'll do this for a super long period of time.
I do find slow carb a lot easier,
a lot easier.
Uh,
and I just had,
for instance,
I'm actually going to test myself while,
while we talk,
but I had a lead on my couch.
I'm not going to lead on your couch.
I had a Kombucha while walking over here that has sugar in it.
Well,
as a grips,
so over the day I'm trying to,
I'm trying to restrain or constrain,
restrict.
There we go.
We're strict my carbs to 30 grams or less for the day and I'm trying to,
I'm trying to restrict my protein to around one gram per kilogram of desired
body weight or lean body weight.
That's it.
Typically the same amount that bodybuilders eat when they want to put mass on?
No,
it's a lot like one gram per pound,
per pound of
body weight I'm doing killed him.
It's less than half.
Um,
and you have to really restrict your protein intake.
If you eat tons of protein,
especially if you drink something like whey protein,
which is the simple sugar of proteins,
it's the liver will convert that via Gluconeogenesis is what it's called into.
Got the,
we've got the scientist in the background.
Give me the thumbs up,
uh,
into,
well they'll take,
the amino acids will be converted into glucose and certain amino acids are
converted preferentially into glucose.
So there,
uh,
Glucogenix as opposed to ketogenic.
So anyway,
it's all very,
very interesting stuff.
One last question for you.
When you're on this day,
can you actually put on mass?
Do you think you could,
if you were lifting,
you'd get bigger?
I think it's possible that I could,
but if I were to do it,
if I were to follow this diet and,
and really want to put on mass,
I would either follow what people call the Tkd,
the targeted Ketogenic Diet or what I've done before when I was in college.
Actually,
the cyclical Ketogenic Diet and the cyclical ketogenic diet is very interesting
and it combines well with the mentality and kind of the ethos of the slow carb
Diet because you have 24 to 48 hours each week to binge basically the carb load.
So you would follow the Ketogenic Diet from say Monday to Friday on Saturday
morning,
you'd do a glycogen depletion workout and then you would carb load for the next
24 to 48 hours.
I would constrain that to 24.
Uh,
and I think if you do that and you're taking advantage of insulin is an anabolic
hormone and driving carbs in that that can help fuel you for high intensity
workouts for say the next two or three days when you get super advanced like a
Peter,
a Tina,
uh,
who is an MD that I've had on the podcast.
We've talked about all sorts of life extension and performance enhancing,
uh,
techniques and tools and dietary tweaks.
Uh,
he is a ketosis master so he will determine he's a,
he's in that,
he's a long distance cyclist and he also,
well actually he wouldn't consider it longest since he does 20 kilometer time
trials I think is 20 kilometer.
And he will,
he can,
he will quantify the exact number of carbohydrates or grams of carbohydrates,
carbohydrates a he can consume and utilize during exercise without popping out
of Ketosis.
Hmm.
Crazy.
Yeah,
he does something.
He only eats those carbs when he's cycling.
That's right.
And then when he's done,
he's like,
I didn't pop up cause I just burned everything straight out.
Yeah.
And he'll measure that based on what he believes his liver can hold.
I think it's something like 400 grams or 400 calories.
I think it's probably 400 calories.
No,
maybe 400 grams.
I'm mixing him.
I'm not this advanced.
I'm just using one of your podcasts.
Yeah,
he's been on the podcast twice.
Sweet.
I'll go.
I'll go listen.
Get a Tia.
A T,
t I a the guy's amazing.
All right.
What else?
Uh,
so other things,
Tim's doing weird,
particularly things over there.
I talked about my whiskey.
Um,
so this is something that I just started getting into,
uh,
last week.
And this little guy right here is called the fresh roast sr 700 sr 700.
It's like a fake movie name,
Dude.
This is,
this is,
it's like a,
the blackbird,
what was that?
The SR 71?
Uh,
that's right.
Yeah.
So,
um,
this is,
uh,
at home coffee roaster.
Like you basically buy the beans,
like straight up green beans.
These are coffee beans before they'd been roasted and you can roast your own
beans inside this little machine.
So essentially what you do is you fill this up.
If I'm going to make enough for just one cup of coffee,
I'll put 25 grams of a,
of beans in here and then put little top on here.
And this will circulate hot air at around,
Oh you,
there's three different temperature settings,
but the high is around 400 degrees,
um,
which is pretty hot.
Uh,
and it fluffs it like popcorn.
So you'll see these little beans jump.
It takes about 10 to 15 minutes and then you'll have a perfectly roasted coffee.
It'll do a cool down period.
Um,
and then you take it out and let it grind it after it sits and you have fresh
roasted coffee at home.
It's pretty awesome.
That's cool.
So I mean it's a way to save money but also at the same time like experimenting
with different types of rows cause you can do your own rose.
How do you like to roast coffee?
Well I just got this thing so I'm really not that far into it.
But one of the things that's really cool about this is it has a Usb port on the
back of it and I plugged it into my computer and you can go in and set your own
cycles so you can set your temperature cycles,
your duration,
and you can have it.
Oh God,
I hate it seemed that,
that hurts dude.
I do that for vitamin D testing.
Um,
oh man.
So anyway,
uh,
check it out.
It's on Amazon.
I will say one thing about that coffee roaster.
Um,
it's not that expensive,
but there have been some people that have issues with the roasts are being
broken when they receive it.
Um,
I had a similar issue where my roaster wasn't getting hot enough.
I did contact them on support.
They were awesome.
They sent me one out without a meeting and this one back.
So they're really good on customer service.
We're based out of Utah.
Um,
it's a fun little hobby.
Some people roast beans in there,
like oven,
they'll put it on a flat pan and restroom beans.
But if you've ever been kind of been curious and wanting to,
uh,
you're being curious.
One of the things I will say is a software does not work,
uh,
on the Mac.
So what I did is I downloaded,
uh,
parallels,
launched windows 10 inside of it,
connected it via USB,
and then ran off from there and it worked just fine.
So anyway,
fun little hobby if you're ever been curious or you get into kind of pour over
coffee at your own house,
this is kind of next level shit.
So,
um,
there's all different types of beans that you can buy.
I got these from a place called Sweet Maria's,
which is based out of Oakland.
Uh,
they have a great online store.
Don't lick your fingers if you're watching the video version of this and it's
disgusting and he's bleeding and licking himself when I'm talking about coffee.
Um,
anyway,
have fun with it.
It's a,
it's a fun gift for the coffee enthusiasts out
there.
You can get started for under a couple hundred bucks or right around a couple
hundred bucks.
That is my next thing.
Was it distracting you've workout?
I mean it's just like,
what are you doing dude?
So I have 0.7 point $7 million for Ketones,
which is not as high as I would like it,
which I attribute to the,
yeah,
to the eight grams of Kombucha or eight grams of carbohydrate income Mucho,
which is all sugar even though I walked about two miles to get here.
Um,
so there,
there you go on and have a glucose of 93,
which is way,
way,
way too high for my,
for my preference.
So that's it.
I'll keep the blood there and off of your kids literally sitting on the couch.
No,
no,
no.
It's on top of the little.
I know,
but that's just like one toaster jump from being in your blood.
It is,
it is definitely one toaster jumps.
A No jumping on the blood toaster.
Uh,
so I have a related suggestion or option for folks and that is,
have you ever done anything with coffee,
by the way?
Are you a coffee guy?
I like coffee,
either grocery and stuff.
I've never roasted my own stuff.
I've done tons of pour over stuff.
I have the air press at home.
I know that's not a pushover,
but I do have the [inaudible],
the [inaudible] and uh,
there's a,
I think there's a Hario version or is that the vcs and he's 60.
There's a no talking about the blue auto one that goes like this.
And
I have a couple of other options,
but I've been doing mostly t the,
uh,
the other option for roasting beans that I've seen is using a popcorn.
Yeah.
Roaster.
This is more or less the same thing.
The same thing with a little bit more control.
And that's what Mark Marin does at home.
I mean,
this thing is,
is,
I mean,
I don't know how much it is.
I can't remember how you paid for it.
I want to say it's no more than $250.
And it could have been 150.
I don't remember that.
Anyway,
it's not that expensive.
Maybe he's expensive,
but if you're really into it,
it's,
uh,
it's pretty awesome.
I enjoyed drinking Kombucha,
but clearly on my current diet,
it's,
it's too much of a pain in my ass and is going to knock me out of Ketosis.
So what I might do to try to get the probiotic,
uh,
sort of bacterial benefit of consuming Kombucha is take this stuff.
So this is saccharomyces Boulardii if I'm getting that right.
Plus Mos,
mos is men and oligosaccharides and uh,
these I will be using to repopulate my gut after the antibiotics that I took
for.
Why this lack of this train though,
that that's what's found in the Kombucha.
So I'm not consuming just that I be consuming this.
I'd be consuming some insulin,
but Indian Lynn can also spike insulin and contains sugars.
So I have to be cautious of how much I consume.
Probably less than 30 grams a day would make obviously a lot of sense from
aiming for a fewer than 30 grams of carbs per day.
And what was that?
What was that?
Oh yeah.
It can make you farty that's true.
Yeah.
So those are,
yeah.
Fructo oligosaccharides that can you socially,
uh,
inappropriate and unfriendly?
Can I prick myself and see where I'm blood your wise?
Uh,
yeah,
sure.
An extra pricker I always have an extra freaker for you.
Uh,
yes I do.
I have an extra printer via clean one.
I'll give you a clean pricker um,
hair.
Do you want me to do it for you or you want to do,
I want to do it myself.
I just want to make sure you not like double pricking me.
You know how much you like double Frickin,
not even here.
You know,
you can put it in yourself.
How do you take the lace lid off?
These are like,
you twist it off.
So put this little guy,
he slipped,
man.
Your vocab is killing.
Isn't that what is,
what does at least they call it?
That's a land set.
Lancet.
Okay.
But you've got to hold it there and push it down pretty hard so that then it
goes,
it's going to protect me right away.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
Get it seated and then you did twist it off.
All right.
We're going to do this.
Ooh Shit.
And then I have a gift for you.
All right.
You want to put that top on?
Okay.
And then,
um,
your bloods on here.
None of my blood's on there.
I'm going to do like on my arm.
Uh,
I mean it's not calibrated for that,
but if you want to do that,
you're welcome to.
You want to do it on your hand?
Yeah,
I don't want to do it.
Like I just don't want to do it in an eye on the fingertips or hurts like a
biatch here.
Gimme that right.
I'm going to do it on my like arm here.
All right.
Go for it.
So I do it over a vein or is that just like Dang Shit,
don't do it.
Just do it.
Do a finger finger would be my suggestion.
But if you want to do your hand,
no,
no.
Here we go.
It was pushing away instead of two,
which I set it at.
Hold on to is fun.
Let me get this thing.
It's three like further in three.
We'll go further in.
Okay,
here we go.
Alright,
hold on a sec.
Let me get this ready so you don't have a hass out before we take your
measurement.
If I just passed out on the show,
let me go for it.
I'm doing,
I didn't feel anything.
Yeah,
I know.
It doesn't hurt.
It didn't hurt at all.
And that's not going to be enough.
You're gonna have to do it again.
They're going to have to do it on your fingers.
The same thing.
Just use the same thing.
How do I reload it?
You pull that thing back.
Okay.
No other side.
Listen.
Yeah.
And then just do your fingertips.
It's not going to work on your form.
Oh,
you know what?
Hold on.
But you're going to need to use the use the alcohol again.
Yeah.
Okay.
Should I say it to really get the job done and you seem to be a poor bleeder.
Oh fuck.
I hate this feeling.
Alright,
there we go.
I didn't even feel it.
Yeah.
All right.
Wow,
man,
you really don't bleed very well.
Um,
let me squeeze.
I can get some shit out of it.
You are not bleeding.
I need to drink some more alcohol.
No Dude.
They drink alcohol to constrict the blood
and thinking about,
I need to do it again
doing it.
You're really shitty.
No,
there's nothing coming out here.
Do the,
you're doing the middle of your finger to the outside edge of your finger right
here.
Yeah.
On the edge.
Okay.
Ah,
that one fucking knows.
Good fucker.
Oh,
that'll probably,
yeah,
there we go.
It's a little better.
Oh,
barely.
Barely.
Keep going.
Oh my God.
I can't believe you're such a shitty bleeder.
Uh,
we're almost there.
We're like halfway there.
You gets here
or there we go.
Oh yeah.
It's close.
It's so close.
This is like the sloppiest fucking
Oh my God.
Yeah.
This is
your folder.
All you just touched on you.
God dammit.
I'm more pissed that you're wasting my God.
Damn.
There we go.
There you guys.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Come on you fucking thing.
It says three.
What does that mean?
Oh fuck it.
Errored out because we took to hold back out again.
You again.
No,
this thing won't work.
We'd have to do it again.
Are you kidding?
No,
he tried to lock me.
I'm gonna do one more then pulled back in a sick way again.
Maybe we'll,
no,
this thing's toast.
We're going to have to do another one.
Oh my God.
I'm bleeding all over the place now.
Okay,
hold on.
Alright,
Sorry.
People will cut it.
Some of this out.
No,
no,
no.
Don't cut this out.
This is Ben.
This is goal.
Uh,
alright,
so I'm going another finger.
Yup.
This is gonna.
This is a really shitty thing to have to do yourself.
I've already cut myself three times.
Now.
You should take it to four.
No.
Three willing to,
Oh,
here we go.
All right,
Ready?
Three,
two,
one.
Take you a second to do it.
Ah,
Jesus.
I'll wait until you're ready.
Let me get a good amount of,
there we go.
All right.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
That's funny.
Okay,
now
you have a bandaid.
I don't have a [inaudible] 87 what does that mean?
Is it good?
It's all right.
What were you I was 90 I think.
93 okay.
You're 87 87 and then go,
oh,
there we go.
What does that,
uh,
in my wait,
was that a ketone stick or blood sugar one,
but I want to ketone all,
I can do another one if you want.
I got it.
Sorry guys.
We'll cut some of this up.
Okay.
It is you got to you if I got enough or good enough.
Ketones,
sorry.
This born Jesus.
Turn on.
Hold on,
hold on.
Okay.
All right.
I guess 0.02 that's my guest.
Now I'm going to give you points of your three.
Oh Shit.
Sorry.
That's what it was.
Subway.
Oh Dude.
How good is that?
Just it,
yeah.
0.3 does that bad.
I guess it exactly.
You're not really in Ketosis,
but you can get there a little bit more work.
You're a point there.
I think I said points through three a minute.
Getting there though.
Yeah.
You got a ways to go,
but uh,
but you're getting there swing,
but on the Keto sticks,
you wouldn't have that level of granularity.
You wouldn't have any way of really telling you go with that dude,
you're bleeding because I have it.
That's why you should suck on your finger.
It'll fix it.
Alright.
That was very exciting.
Okay.
People,
sorry for the,
all right.
Weird episode.
That was great.
I have a gift for you.
Okay.
Maybe you can put on your finger.
Don't put any finger,
uh,
this,
this is sue grew.
You ever seen this done?
Oh,
it does this.
So it's multiple glue.
It's,
I believe originally from the UK and my,
my mom gave it to me for Christmas last year.
It is kind of,
imagine if,
uh,
like super glue and Plato had a love child.
It'd be something like this.
You can use it to fix anything.
Like if you have a,
a cracked handle on a pot,
you could fix it and mold it and it won't stick your fingers and then it will
solidify and it will,
it'll,
it,
it'll become completely held together for those hard to glue things.
Yep.
You could use it for repairing,
saying iPhone cases cracked.
You could use it.
It's not really solely glue.
You could actually people,
I've seen people use Subaru to make mounts for cameras.
Um,
I've seen them use it for turns into rubber is what it's saying.
Yeah.
The 24 hours.
Basically.
Yeah,
exactly.
Huh.
It's a moldable glue that turns into rubber so you could make toys out of it.
You can do just about anything crazy.
Pretty cool.
Awesome.
Thanks Dan.
Yeah,
definitely.
So how did you,
I mean,
is this,
you had this land rent at home or why did you decide to give me this gift today?
I appreciate it because I liked the stuff and I got so,
so,
uh,
I figured out pass that along.
Awesome.
And uh,
so other,
other stuff that people may not have seen before,
uh,
this is an antiinflammatory Gel,
which is pretty controversial,
uh,
partially because it's,
see,
it's labeled as homeopathic and I have issues with so called homeopathic
medicine and I've written about this before so you can search Tim Ferriss,
homeopathic medicine if you want to see my take on it.
But,
um,
the short version that generally homeopathic medicine has no evidence for its
efficacy.
But,
uh,
this stuff,
trauma meal is incredibly effective for injury repair and for antiinflammatory
purposes.
If you have some type of,
of tear or otherwise.
So I use this stuff all the time.
I did mention this in the four hour body.
Is it like a been gay type stuff?
Like we're just burns and feels good and kind of loosens up the muscle or it's
not just say the Menthol,
typically the venues of the world use menthol and so on for that.
Um,
this seems to have some type of curative effect or restorative effect,
not just a temporary numbing effect.
Um,
so these is like post workout.
Like what are you primarily using this for?
Like,
well,
I tore,
I,
I have a minor tear of my right hamstring at the insertion point at the hip.
So I'm using this,
I could have used this like a year ago when I ripped a muscle.
This stuff's great for that.
So,
um,
I've seen some miraculous recoveries including this.
This isn't sufficient by itself.
But if you were to combine this with say,
uh,
some,
electric stimulation with a device like the mark to uh,
or some type of ultrasound and then apply this,
this,
uh,
this can work some wonders.
So anyway,
for those people who haven't seen it traumeel easy to find now.
It used to be really hard to find.
Now I think you can get it at whole foods and they're also a ingestible
versions,
but I tend to use the topical sweep.
Yeah.
What else do you have a,
so a couple things.
One,
I decided to do a experiment and ventured down into some more photography and
um,
I picked up this camera.
A buddy of mine recommended this camera.
It's a Leica.
Um,
this is the em dash p and a
feel how heavy that thing is.
First of all,
I don't know if you've ever messed around with a Leica before.
Uh,
I do not have any like,
uh,
but that is a heavy camera.
Yeah,
it's,
it's pretty bad ass.
So I just got this,
I'm just learning about it.
Um,
if any people have any recommendations or they actually shooting like as of any
good books that I can pick up,
um,
I would love to hear them.
So just tweet at me at Kevin Rose.
But the thing I love about this is it's completely manual.
Like everything from sending the f stops up here,
there is no auto focus,
so you manually focus up here,
you get your shutter speed right here,
set your ISO in the back,
like everything is manual.
So you know,
you probably nail like one in every 10 photos,
but when you nail one it's just like unbelievable and it's very beautiful and it
has a very kind of vintagey feel like,
let me show you some of these uh,
these photos that I'll give a
oh,
is that only have one on their team and I only have one on there.
Um,
I,
I sucked him off and I told him to delete on my computer but sucked them all
out.
You guys have been,
you've been drinking.
I love that.
My wife is like double,
double brickton sucking.
How was it that sucked them all off.
Got Your anyway,
so like of stuff
is fun.
Uh,
I'll give grandma a couple of photos that you can put on here,
but it creates these really very beautiful vivid photos.
Um,
if you're into,
I dunno,
I'm kind of like getting into this stage of my life where I liked more manual
things.
Like I'm not about technology,
I'm trying to get away from it a little bit.
One of the,
one of the models that they have,
I think that you'll think this is kind of interesting.
They have this special edition version of that camera is digital camera.
No LCD on the back,
no preview.
So you take the photos and we literally hook it up to your computer and you
can't sit there and look like until you actually suck them off forcing you,
you can't see what they look like.
It's a cycle off.
This is like a mystery party.
Glory Hole.
This is exciting.
I love it is my wife is like
them all.
But I know what you mean about manual illiteracy and just wanting to use your
hands more to build things and to do things as opposed to simply being in front
of a screen,
uh,
eight to 16 inches away from blue light or even like,
so by the time this happens it hits the,
a apple watch will be out and it's like,
what do you think about that?
Are you going to get one of those?
I,
I'm not going to get one because I have enough devices.
I don't need a watch.
I have time on my phone.
I don't need to put,
and I don't need to read you racked with anything else,
but anything pull you in.
Like let's say the center has got really good and you could monitor,
well you can real time,
24,
seven heart rate with it.
That's interesting.
Yeah,
it's okay.
Um,
events,
the data is only interesting to me and so much as I can use it.
So I'm probably not going to do much with that then.
Yeah,
I feel like it's,
I,
I'm going to get one because I have two and a half to play within all that,
but I just don't need more.
You,
you don't,
if you,
you ever try and text him after 6:00 PM it just doesn't go through.
You shut your phone off.
Yeah.
I put my phone on,
on a airplane,
on airplane mode.
Like it's on airplane mode right now.
But you do that all the time?
I do.
Yeah.
Why is that?
Uh,
because I don't want to be reactive and I don't want to feel like I have the
universe going,
hey,
fuck face,
which is what it is,
which is what getting messages feels like to me.
Well,
and that's the problem with the,
the Apple Watch,
to be honest.
Like I want more of that.
I was with a buddy to this morning,
we had coffee and he had went on and he was just like,
and it was just like,
I'm like,
what are we looking at there?
What was that?
And he's just like,
oh,
it was just a little thing and let me know about this and that.
And I was like,
I don't know,
man,
that just seems like one more,
our brains are like,
I don't know how you feel about this,
but when you get 30 tabs open in your web browser and you're doing all these
different things,
there's no focus anymore.
And all of a sudden that that plays out in how you see everything.
And I worry that like,
I have a hard enough time keeping a conversation with my wife or anyone else at
dinner.
Like with my phone sitting there,
it's like,
you know,
we always have this like,
she's like,
can you put your phone away?
Like it says it like multiple times a week.
Yeah.
And it's important.
It's important that we get this stuff out of an off of us.
No,
I agree.
That's why I think,
you know,
putting your phone on airplane mode,
at the very least,
I put my phone on airplane mode and I put it face down when I'm having dinner.
Uh,
typically since it's on airplane mode or I have it awful,
just put it my punishing you a different mode.
Do you know about the little sleepy mode?
Uh,
I have used do not disturb mode,
but this is also a chance to show people that maybe this wasn't,
uh,
so I've upgraded to the tablet and the phone,
tablet,
worst case ever.
Why don't you get that case?
Because I care less about how it looks and I care more about it.
Preventing my phone from breaking.
No,
I know,
but there's a nice leather ones.
I'll get you one.
So in any case,
I got this monstrous thing and a,
I'm quite fond of it.
And in part of the reason I'm fond of it is I experimented with going without my
laptop,
but I don't like tapping on the iPhone screen.
I hate,
I hate producing content with my thumbs.
It makes me insane and it's really slow.
So what I ended up doing,
uh,
when I was traveling,
so it's not using vanity fair,
but rather using this tiny thing that I can put inside a magazine or a book to
protect it.
This is a logic keyboard that's uh,
that's Bluetooth and you just,
you turn it on,
just,
you flip the switch here and I can balance this phone.
It's not really balancing.
Lean it against like a glass of water or something and then type in the same way
that I would type on a laptop but I'm only traveling with that and to have those
like Microsoft server,
you could just get an iPad two and do,
I don't like I had snow because then I have this plus basically half of the
laptop.
Do you what I mean it's,
it's bigger and I don't need a larger screen than this for most of the type
thing that I do and the fact that we feel this thing,
how light that is,
it's so light,
so I hadn't,
the battery life lasts eight.
We'll ages once you've charged it up via USB,
it's actually pretty good.
It's really light.
I have a the new air coming.
Have you seen it?
I haven't ate super tiny dude like half the size last ones.
Sorry.
It's not there anymore.
It's just all imac was so I didn't get the brand new.
I just got a new Mac book and I made sell it.
What size is it?
It's fine.
It's a 13 inch.
The new one is like that dude.
And it's like that thin,
it's insane.
Like if you're looking for portability,
that's the only one to get.
Yeah.
So in any case that is another experiment in mobility.
I think this is,
is a,
is going to be super useful for 99% of what I do.
Cool.
Um,
aside from,
from storage and then,
uh,
let's see,
this is,
this is kind of funny,
but um,
so this,
this is the book that I've got a,
it's not a book,
it's a magazine mark.
So I have been like,
I feel like,
I feel like a,
this is,
people might get pissed about this,
but whatever.
I feel like a bride to be.
Maybe not you,
Daria.
I'm not sure.
But a lot of women who feel like all like,
no,
like go wedding crazy.
I'm not saying,
I don't know if you did or not,
but a lot they have all the wedding magazines.
Do you what I'm talking about?
She never had one.
But anyway.
Ah,
okay.
So anyway,
when people are getting ready for something,
a big event like getting married,
having a kid,
they start reading all the baby magazines,
parenting magazines,
the wedding magazines,
whatever the hell.
And so I've been putting off getting a dog.
So I started reading magazines
and the cover is what got me all you need,
all you need is love with this dog.
Like,
and I was like,
Oh,
I got stabbed in the heart.
And so this is about,
is San Francisco's you get uh,
the sub,
the sub title is dog is my copilot.
That's funny.
Okay.
And then it's the dog culture magazine.
It's just like the most SF hipster thing imaginable.
So what do you,
have you narrowed it down to any breeds yet?
What is pretty good?
Actually I was enjoying reading yesterday,
had the history of the seeing eye dog,
which I was very excited about.
Uh,
I'm going to get a dog and we rescue.
It'll definitely be a rescue and it's,
it's a matter of just doing it and stop stopping all the thinking I think is
what it comes down to.
I think there's no good time to get a dog,
have baby make any huge decision.
You just have to,
that's going to really do it.
And then you're a world traveler.
It's tough.
I am,
but I,
you know,
I love San Francisco so much and I'm spending more time in La and then New York,
it's really three locations where I spend 90% of my time and if I'm going to be
gone for any period of time,
I would take,
figure out a way to take the dog with me.
So I'm not too too worried about that.
Um,
I think in smaller size,
bigger size,
what do you pay?
Like 30 pounds.
30,
40.
Yeah.
It will be interesting.
I need to,
I need a dog that I can kind of swap,
play with and wrestle,
play with without wondering if I'm going to get up
somehow dislocate a hip or a juicer.
Gimme the toaster.
It's very hesitant.
Hey,
go.
Telstra is a 25 pounds,
25 pounds in growing.
He's a good guy.
Cores,
light and grain.
It's going on now.
He doesn't drink.
It doesn't drink.
Oh,
that's right.
[inaudible] has the most incredible negative response to alcohol I've ever seen,
which is just witness.
You go like this with a glass of wine.
He just back pedals from like five feet away from the glass.
Yeah,
he does not like here.
Here's an example of toast.
Torture him.
I tell him to come here.
It's okay.
All right,
so I've got,
I've,
I've a book to share with people.
Well,
hold on.
You've been like three in a row then,
right?
Go,
go,
go for it.
So,
um,
I have a quarterly box coming out similar to Tim's quarterly box.
Um,
I think mine is,
I don't know my URL anyway,
you can search Google quarterly.
Kevin Rose in my next box and whether you subscribe to my box or not,
I really don't care.
I'm just telling you about this.
This is matcha tea from breakaway.
Watch it.
You've had this before break way before,
right?
It's good.
It's great.
Montia for people that don't know and people like myself that have way too much
caffeine in their life or I should say too much coffee in my life and you want
something that's a little bit more healthy and a change.
Macia is essentially the entire leaf of the tea plant ground up.
So they take these um,
very large,
very heavy kind of um,
what does it there may out of there man.
Huh?
You seen these connectors?
They're stone but they're heavy stones and they grind them into a very fine
green powder.
So this is kind of what a actually thought open.
Uh,
but you don't want to spill it on your website.
We can show you,
we can show you a picture online but you take a little,
what I do is I take a little tiny scoop of this,
put it in the bottom and then add a little bit of hot water just about that
much.
Buy a coffee for author and then you use that in froth.
The very bottom of it,
it'll create this almost like foamy type substance.
And then you add more hot water and you have like a green tea latte.
It's a great caffeine boost.
Um,
and it's just the foam.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Well you don't get as much hand that way.
It's,
well,
we don't want that.
I like,
I like a good for me head on the anti much.
Of course it's like I,
it's better to start off and do it at initially rather than wait until the end.
Then you suck them all off and get the double Prek.
I'm the one drinking and you're the one,
oh,
it was amazing.
No,
I want this to continue.
I can just do my last one.
Oh good.
All right.
This is awesome.
Uh,
do you know what does this,
I don't think I can guess.
So this,
okay.
Go ahead and guess fermenting.
Correct.
So,
um,
don't say.com and so this is a gift I actually owned fermenting dot.
Come on.
That's why it's funny.
I'm doing nothing with Oh yeah.
So if you ever want to do something with it,
I'm good.
But somebody in the,
uh,
so internet as people that we've talked about this before on the show fermenting
is great.
Um,
you get a lot of a helpful,
friendly bacteria that grow on fermented foods and it also makes a lot of foods
more bioavailable.
Thanks Ben.
Um,
and basically what this vessel is,
my good friend Tony Conrad gave this as a gift for my birthday.
And this is a,
a a clay vessel that is made by a company called a counterculture pottery.
And so these two guys right here,
these are two little clay tablets.
Um,
and what happens is you start off with whatever you want to ferment.
So in this case,
what I like to do a lot of is sauerkraut.
So you follow a simple little recipe.
It's as easy as taking some cabbage,
kind of Michigan all together with some salt,
adding some caraway seeds,
whatever else you want to add.
You put it in here and then you,
you take these apart and these are your weights.
And then what happens is when that all those cell walls of the cabbage
breakdown,
they put off a lot of just basically water.
And when these weights sit on top of the cabbage,
it pushes it down beneath the waterline.
So they're fully submerged underneath the fluid,
which is important because you don't want that exposed cabbage floating out
there and getting kind of like contact with air.
So after that's done,
you have in the kettle,
you're ready to ferment them for a couple of weeks.
Yeah,
you put the lid on.
Now most people think,
okay,
well that's it.
But that's not the reason why there's this little groove right here is you
filled this groove with water.
And then what happens is as is for men's and the gas tries to escape.
What you want is the gas they get out,
but no more air to get in.
You don't want anything contaminating the fermentation as it's going on.
So it's all,
yeah,
so it's solid.
So what happens is it'll bubble and little bubbles would come out of the side
here,
but the air,
the air,
right?
So that comes out to the water.
That's very clever with that.
Or bacteria,
which is the most important thing.
You don't want bacteria getting in there cause this is like,
you've got a lot of like warmth and fermentation going on in here.
So that's it.
This is,
this is by far,
you'll see a lot of these on Amazon.
A bunch of are crap.
I can't believe my friend found this.
This is by far.
I've been into fermenting for a while.
I've looked at a ton of different vessels by far the best.
So culture,
pottery,
counterculture,
pottery correctly.
Yeah.
So I don't know how much it was a gift.
I don't know how much she's run.
I didn't look it up and I'm not going to,
but it's beautiful.
It is like this is awesome.
If you want to get into fermenting in a serious way,
they have some great recipes in here to this little instruction booklet.
It is so simple to do your own sauerkraut.
Seriously.
If you've never tried it,
um,
I recommend it.
That is all I have
today.
All right,
so I've got two more things to talk about this too.
I don't know if you want to talk about this.
Oh,
sure.
We can talk about this.
Uh,
well,
I mean,
I'm going to need you to elaborate here,
but I've been getting on my very,
very boring ketogenic diet eating eggs.
But the,
one of the ways to make eggs more interesting for me is to just perfect soft
boiled eggs where you have this like delicious,
almost caramel,
like,
uh,
nectar of the yolk inside the egg,
which is effectively the soft layers har.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so I love softball.
Boiled eggs,
the neck by the room.
But there are,
this is where this is a performance Kevin video show.
Anyway.
So yeah,
part of the challenge is if you're trying to really get the perfect softball egg
and you don't boil the egg long enough,
then it just comes out as this just like my asthma of disgusting goop and then
it's no good.
Right.
So,
uh,
so when I'm,
when I'm doing a,
generally I am doing,
uh,
I like to use baking soda if possible,
which will reduce adherence to the shell.
Uh,
but I will get it to a boil the water that is,
and then I will reduce it to a low boil sort of low turbulence,
add the eggs in and leave them in for about five minutes.
Usually five to six minutes is kind of perfect for me,
but it's still a bit of guesswork.
Uh,
and this device you guys told me about when we went out to dinner the other
night,
which is effectively a steamer as I understand it,
it's amazing and it's a single use device that will give you perfect softball
decks.
And I was like,
oh my God,
I don't generally have single use devices.
Darian doesn't ever really,
but this is the one you guys use this.
Yeah,
I bought this thing in our egg hen years ago and uh,
well let me show you how it works.
Yeah.
So it's pretty straight forward.
All you do is,
this is the base plate that gets hot.
You add in like two tablespoons
how much oil you want and how many eggs you have.
Right?
There's a little recipe in the water,
but it tells you how much to put in.
So anyway,
I was just like generalizing.
You add just a little bit of water in the bottom.
Then you put the eggs inside of these little holes right here.
So you set them in,
boom,
boom.
If you want to actually crack the eggs up and put them into here,
this will make poached eggs.
Um,
and then,
I don't even know,
I never knew what these were for.
Did you find that name?
Oh,
that's more,
I don't know.
Anyway,
all I ever did was put them in there.
You put the lid on and like you hit this little switch right here on and it
automatically shuts itself off.
It's is because it's just off in the water on that.
Right,
right.
Okay.
Got It.
So you,
yeah.
You need to get the amount of water
right.
Kevin lost a piece,
but the most important pieces
I did lose that.
Or uh,
like you basically are like,
I want four eggs,
software and okay,
I see a measuring cup.
Okay,
that's awesome.
That's the magic amount because that determines the duration and everything.
Cool.
It's so easy.
And this thing,
I think it was Alandra 30 bucks.
It's not that expensive.
Cool thought that years and years ago.
Uh,
this is a book that
not many of you have seen.
Probably it is,
it is a new book as I understand it and it is called a wrestling life.
And the,
uh,
wrestling life is a collection of stories about Dan Gable and by Dan Gable.
And,
uh,
I never give cover quotes,
just don't do it.
But Dan Gable was and still is a hero of mine.
And when I was growing up,
because he was sportsman of the century according to this sports illustrated,
he is one of the best coaches of last hundred years and widely considered that
in any sport.
Uh,
he won the gold medal in the Munich Olympics in wrestling without having a
single point scored on him,
which is like winning Wimbledon without having points scored on you.
It's just impossible.
And uh,
he was able then to take that people thought he was already at the pinnacle.
Okay.
It's all downhill from here as it,
as it is the case for a lot of athletes.
And then he went into coaching and was able to just produce monsters on demand.
He created this just factory of mutants and I think he had something like 200
plus a somewhere between 150 200 all Americans out of that one,
uh,
out of,
the Iowa Hawkeyes and 10,
I'm sorry.
So I think it was like 13 big 10 in a row and,
and that might be getting some of the facts a little off.
But,
uh,
he was,
he only lost one match and his entire Ncaa career,
which was his last match,
that's why he was so pissed that he trained seven hours a day,
seven days a week before the Munich Olympics and just rolled through everybody.
Uh,
and he is really aggressive.
So I did put up a blog post at one point called Ode to aggression,
which has a clip of 10 Gable,
a coaching his wrestlers,
which is phenomenal.
So Google that,
oh,
do aggression,
Dan Gable.
But my quote that I,
that I gave because I think it's very appropriate,
is in a modern world of political correctness and glad handing the art of the
fight is highly undervalued,
allowed Dan to show you another way,
because Dan is a fighter.
Uh,
and uh,
that's it.
So this book,
you can check it out if you want to get an inkling of why I'm so fascinated with
Dan gable a as is John Irving for instance,
who's,
who calls Dan Gable,
one of his heroes meeting him changed my life.
Uh,
his life as a wrestler,
as a coach,
as a man dedicated to his family,
has served me as a model.
Uh,
and it just,
it's an amazing story.
So check out the book or just a,
you can,
you can Google Ode to aggression and take a look at Dan Gable.
I think,
uh,
it will,
it will really leave an indelible mark on your thinking because,
uh,
with this guy has been able to do as a coach and a teacher,
a impresses me more than what he did as an athlete.
And what he did as an athlete at the time was basically unprecedented.
Uh,
so that's that.
And then the,
the big news,
the biggest news for me,
which involves you,
uh,
is,
when people are watching this at by this time,
they should be able to go to iTunes and get the entire season of the Tim Ferriss
experiment,
the TV show.
And this has been something I fought for for so long and if I did a lawyer up
and negotiate for a year to get the rights back,
no one has seen 11,
I think of the,
of the 13 episodes and most people haven't seen any,
uh,
done with the team that filmed and edited all of Anthony Bordain stuff.
Super Gritty,
super cinematic.
Um,
we were in the three gun shooting episode together and uh,
it was just an amazing experience.
So I finally have that.
I've hours of bonus footage.
I'm also going to make that available.
And so you can see,
uh,
me basically pushing myself to the breaking point.
And you do see a lot of injuries and some of these episodes for park core,
professional poker,
Rally Car Racing,
surfing,
Brazilian Jujitsu,
and you want to see like ribs get broken.
You can check that one with Marcello Garcia,
who's like the Michael Jordan of the sport and all of them are available.
So you can get it for like,
I dunno,
40 or 50% off if you buy the whole season on iTunes.
So if you go to itunes.com forward slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and two s's,
uh,
or if you just got a four hour workweek.com forward slash TV which is going to
be,
I think it's going to be,
it's going to be cheap.
Can Be like 1499 something like that for 13 episodes.
Awesome.
It's really
cheap.
So I'm excited.
I still haven't seen our episode.
I know that you have it now.
I got to see it.
I've been I every time,
well I should say everything,
but I've seen you hell times and I've always brought the hard drive and you make
fun of me because you're like,
who walks around with a hard drive in this day and age?
And I'll tell you he's saying
their bitcoin information because they don't want to have it in the cloud.
This isn't bitcoin.
This is like an episode of your freaking.
But my big,
my big card,
the,
these episodes,
the TV show and also not getting sued by Turner Broadcasting for putting stuff
out that isn't or restricted,
which my rights,
uh,
requiring me to do is worth more to me than my bitcoin.
So it makes sense that I would take similar perception.
This is what I said to Tim when he got here and he's like,
I have my hard drive.
I'm like,
let me get a copy of that.
And he's like,
no,
I can't give you a copy.
I'm like,
how can you not give me a copy in my hard drive is encrypted the odds that
someone hacks into my laptop and then,
well,
maybe not after this episode.
And then downloads a four gigabyte files that had,
it was like 10 gigs.
This is download this random video and then puts it online where you get in
trouble.
It's like,
it's like one in the bazillion and you still won't do it.
One in a bazillion.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I mean you could say also,
all right,
well,
you know,
it's,
it's like,
so the risk reward multiplied by the probability I get,
I'd get it.
He's the,
you've always been a little paranoid.
That's fine.
I've fall.
Yeah,
little paranoid.
Just sort of an understatement.
But it's just trying to be nice and I appreciate that.
So check out the show,
Tim Ferriss experiment.
It's a super proud of it.
I literally almost killed myself doing it.
And if you liked any of this stuff in the books,
you know,
the four hour workweek for our body,
for our chef,
all of my favorite concepts and most powerful and flexible principles are in the
show.
We had a lot of fun shooting in our episode.
You should check out the,
the gun shoot.
It was a pretty intense competition.
It was fun.
Really close.
I don't want to spoil it for people that like it was a re pretty much.
Yeah.
Now close to like we were in the competition and how fast we could run through
the course.
We need to switch to the three different guns,
handgun,
shotgun and an ar 15 and so you were,
I mean very,
very and we both got a lot better.
Yeah.
Which is crazy.
So you can check it out.
That's what the sort of savant of the sport and in Taran Butler,
who's,
that guy is shocking to me,
loadings and saying even that is these off the hip shooting.
He isn't,
he's like off the hip and going to hit any target.
He's basically,
it's insane.
You know,
Amy,
I hadn't gunning prodigy.
He can run through the course,
get groupings like this from one to target from the hip while running a like to
it faster than that.
It's like you watch him,
you'll see in the episode z feature in there as well,
I'm sure.
Right.
Well,
I mean,
I know he was instructing as all Yang and running.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And
you can say,
yeah,
you remember when we did el Presidente Day when there's like a drill where you,
you have to spin around draw,
I guess it's double tap,
double tap,
drop the MAG reload,
double tap and turn.
Did it to
like 1.5,
seven seconds.
It was something I remember both of us were just like,
what?
What is so crazy?
I wouldn't have even believed it was the weirdest thing is a big dude.
Like the big day.
Yeah.
He's not a little barrel ballerina.
I mean,
this is a solid guy and kill us.
So easy.
Yeah,
you can clear the entire time I was there,
I was like,
this guy could just turn around and kill us and we have no,
we couldn't even run.
You just make pop up on the debt.
Well,
you know what was funny,
I remember when,
uh,
when we were prepping the episode and I was like,
yeah,
you know,
I have a block 34.
And,
uh,
I wanted to become more comfortable with the guns I already owned and the Glock
34 at some point I'd like to use for competition.
So,
uh,
like EPA or something like that,
the International Defensive Pistol Association,
something like that.
In any case,
uh,
so I was talking to,
he's talking to Taryn beforehand and I was like,
Hey,
is there any chance that you have any glocks that I can use any?
Because I have 40 glocks.
Of course you have 40 glocks.
Yeah.
Uh,
but yeah,
exactly.
And he customizes these.
So now this is the last guy's house you'd ever want to break.
Oh my God.
Cute.
Imagine I was new.
He could take out 40 people.
Oh,
I guarantee you if like we all raided his house and like all our friends,
we would all die.
Oh yeah.
Without a doubt.
Let's see.
When you watch the episode,
he's incredible.
So anyway,
for each of the episodes we have some crazy superhuman type of teacher like
that.
For surfing it was Laird Hamilton,
you know,
the undisputed King of Big Wave Surfing and on and on and on.
So check it out.
A four hour workweek.com forward slash TV.
Sweet.
I think that's it.
Suck them all off.
What did,
what did Graham have to say?
There was something you we were talking about before we started the episode that
I thought was interesting.
You had one thing to say.
You're like,
oh blah,
blah blah.
And I was like,
oh,
that's really interesting.
Grabbed me.
She talk about on the show the fact that everyone in this room is wearing v neck
gray shirts.
No,
it wasn't greening something else.
Some point he had to make.
Oh Wow.
It's over.
Grandkids is it?
And you can have like,
you can laugh at like a 10 minute talk at the camera after it's [inaudible].
It's like Graham Graham show.
You should do that sometimes.
We don't ever watch the entire episode.
Sexy time.
We can splice in Alissa.
Shots of Graham like fight club.
Just you should splice in like a shot of you in the bathtub with like candles
around.
It's like Graham's little private hour.
All right,
we're gonna sorry.
I think that's about it.
Anything else?
That's it.
Uh,
yeah,
we'll see what was good.
I'm heading to,
uh,
to New York for a week and then I'm back.
I don't know where to shoot again,
but we'll figure it out.
Okay.
Not The people.
That's why it's the random show.
I'm glad any other confessions.
Now I'm logistics updates.
All right guys,
Ferris
bestselling author and Human Guinea pig.
I'll show you how to make the impossible possible by bending the rules.
I'll find the world's best teachers and push myself to the edge to deconstruct,
decode,
and demystify some of the world's toughest challenges in record time
if I can do it.
So can you,
one of the best ways to learn something fast as to set stakes.
Everybody that wants you to give it up for Mister Tim Ferriss over there now.
So here it goes.
Hey,
you could feel the power rising up in your loins five days.
This is like the first time I looked at Chinese characters.
Zero experience,
you're in,
you're in trouble.
Okay.
And the world's best teachers
is four or five days were really enough time.
I have my doubts.
Sometimes accelerated learning requires serious acceleration.
The course is designed to kill you,
so here it goes and 50% excited and 50% totally scared shitless.
Five days you've got a fitbit.
Sure.
Accelerator F zero experience,
but I'm terrified of it,
but I did not.
Clay would be a good driver and the world's best teachers.
One mistake and you and your car are toast.
Stand by camera three.
I've never been to the Philippines.
Sally's speak.
One word of Tagalo in that is,
thank you Stella.
All you're telling me we speak like a Filipino now with language learning
experts on my side.
I will find out just how much Tagalog I can cram in four days and this is the
day of reckoning for Tim.
Are you ready
this week?
I'm throwing down.
You're rushing past to step.
I've got to learn fast and it's not going to be tricky.
Five days to train.
I am getting a little deep
and the world's best teachers at least nice adjustment.
What comes out.
All right,
you ready?
Let's go.
You ready for this?
Ready is a little name this week.
I'll attempt to prove that man can fly
the trees,
rings that fear into it.
Five days.
Zero experience.
The danger of permanent damage.
He's a rope insurance and the world's best teacher.
The end goal is to move into real world environments.
Total golf through what?
A three wood,
five days.
Zero experience and the world's best teachers.
We need to clear the mind.
Yeah.
Avoid catastrophes.
Take a chill pill.
I don't
feel like I need to pass punch.
Accelerated learning can be applied to anything.
They broken down the art of attraction to an exact sites.
Really anything.
Having an animal,
it's like crack.
Five days.
I stutter,
I stammer.
My hands are sweating.
Millions efficiency back in ninth grade and the world's best teachers,
eh?
I'm sure you married by Saturday this week.
I'm using my startup experience to help a novice entrepreneur.
I'm a little scared.
I've just four days to set her on a new path and hopefully give her the tools to
unlock her full potential.
This week it's trial by fire.
Weapon is hot,
range is hot.
I have to learn fast.
One 63 your fastest draw.
These are going about 1280% it's not going to be easy and he misses
four days to train in the world's best teachers here to ready.
Standby.
When I say if I can do it,
so can you.
I mean it very literally this week up through the learning curve as alternate a
novice swimmer into a long distance swimming.
Every time I look at the ways and the open water,
I get really nervous with help from the master who taught me.
I know these steps where in just five days,
Sarah is struggling.
Sometimes to learn fast,
you have to slow way down.
The only thing that there is is that now,
maybe that's the most honest way to be four days,
one badass legend.
You think you haven't paddle again and some seriously unpredictable terrain.
Turn at Callaway.
Yotam.
Here we go.
This week I'm going all in.
Nothing gets me learning faster than putting money on the line.
Hi and a nervous wreck.
I've never played a hand in making me look very foolish here
Liz is when my head explodes.
If you think there's nothing you can do when disaster strikes,
I think again,
in just four days,
I'll build a toolkit for survival,
my end game to be ready for anything.
Oh,
hey guys,
this is Tim Ferriss.
Hirums having my tea and my,
what would you attempt if you knew you could not fail mug and for all of the
episodes of the Tim Ferriss
experiment,
go to four hour work week.com forward slash,
TB and it's if all you are,
et Cetera,
et cetera.com forward slash TV where you will find not only all 13 episodes of
the Tim Ferriss experiment that you will find extended interviews really in
depth tutorials,
two to three hour indepth dissections of some of these experts in their skills,
tons of stuff that we just couldn't put into 21 or 22 minutes of television,
but for all of it behind the scenes stuff,
all sorts of cool things with every type of variety.
Go to four hour workweek.com forward slash TV and thank you for watching.